what's up guys and welcome to the
pregame
yeah man
we
are back listen guys if you haven't
liked shared or subscribed you better do
it right now and if you have watched two
or more
of our videos
and you ain't subscribed then we got
beef okay we have beef so you better
start sharing liking and subscribing
right
now
okay
in the building today
we have two guests okay today we're
gonna be talking about submission and
marriage
okay we're gonna be talking about
submission and marriage it could get a
little bit spicy
it could get a little spicy as you guys
can already see my name is pearl just
pearly things is what i go by um i have
had my transition and you guys need to
respect my pronouns today okay yes i am
now a six foot two handsome black male
this is pearl okay so if you guys didn't
know that by now
now you know okay now you know
all right
so
um
today we have two people on our cell
phone welcome yourselves um we're gonna
go around and ask
who you are
uh i'm gonna ask who you are your age
and your relationship status so go for
it boy okay hello my name is ashley
durant i am 21 years old and i am an
actor i live in london
and my relationship status is i'm single
okay i'm a single man
lonely
my name is alexa asme i'm 18 years old
i'm an actress public speaker poet
writer facilitator the list goes on um
i'm single
and yeah
all right then um so
ash
and alexa two ace we're going to get
into it so this week there was a viral
video
right there was a vowel video and there
was a lady named by the name of ali okay
it's pearl's friend it's my friend
that's america i was in miami this week
yeah
yeah with my friend ali yeah i was in
miami
yep i know ali i was in um miami with
ali and i asked ali about her marriage
she showed her ring
and i asked her as pearl right
how did she get this awesome job of
being a wife and she said
that she became a better person
she became submissive
right
so
that
sent women crazy
okay
for for some reason we're gonna delve
into that today um
so i'm gonna ask the woman first okay
alexa um what did you think of the video
first of all
um
i think there were parts that i agreed
with and there were parts that i
disagreed with it but before i get into
my own opinion i do find it quite
interesting
that
i mean i guess this is just social media
but i definitely do find it interesting
how
people are so quick to comment on other
people's relationship statuses i mean
this woman is clearly married she's
clearly happily married she's having the
time of her life it is successful
is it really our business to judge
but i'm going to say anyways um me
personally i think yeah there were some
parts i agreed with as part i disagreed
with
as someone who is currently excelling in
their career
um relationships aren't really a
priority of mine
um but i have been in relationships
before
um i'm not married evidently i have not
lived with a person before so i guess i
do not have the experience
of women who are in those positions to
fully comment but i think me personally
with the way
i still want to be able to
have my sense of identity and autonomy
when it comes to a relationship i still
want to be my own person i still want to
maintain my career
and my success and i love what i do i
love the things that i work on
i enjoy working and i personally
wouldn't want to be a stay-at-home wife
for the rest of my life that doesn't
sit right with me
however
i definitely do believe in
providing for a person
i definitely do believe in cooking and
cleaning i love cooking um and i
definitely but i do think it goes both
ways i think
if i'm the person who comes home first
and my partner hasn't come home yet i'll
happily cook i'll happily clean i'll
happily do what i need to do if my
partner comes home first i would prefer
him to cook or him to clean or whatever
i just think
i don't mind putting in the effort i
don't mind submitting if you wish to
call it that to my partner but
i would want the energy to be
reciprocated i think a lot of the times
i hear
men
wanting women to submit to their
partners
as a way of control
as a way of
okay she submits to me so
i can do whatever i want
i think my way of submitting to a
partner is i submit to you because i
love you and because you love me you
show me the love and affection and you
meet my needs and my desires
and if you do that
then i'm happy
to put in as much effort
and meet your needs and desires
yeah okay interesting ash you saw the
video yeah i did i did see the video
what did you think with that
like like she said that like
people very
like want to be involved with people's
business and the day she's getting her
back you know like she's in a situation
where
she can she can do that she can do i
feel like people wish
that they were in that situation i feel
like if they were in that situation
they wouldn't be complaining in the
comments you know what i mean
so but with the submission thing it's a
thing where
for like
i feel like it's like the word
submission right now today
that's a bad word you know me like oh
wait when you oh you always be
submissive what you want me to get on my
knees and that like people are not going
to mess with that but there's there's a
posit
can we say there's a there's a positive
like outtake of being submissive like
people people don't see that like that
view
of the word bit of being like submissive
but
i just thought like
my personal opinion on the video
actually is a thing where
she chose she wants to be there so that
she's can't do what she's in if she can
meet her husband's needs and she likes
doing it let that girl do her thing
you understand but it's a thing where
people in the comments are saying
telling her how the way she should live
her life you know what matter is like
my life and you're telling me how the
way i should live it and not be this
when i'm happy doing this i agree but
you're telling me
no over the screen no you shouldn't live
like this you should be you should be
doing stuff for yourself oh she's happy
bro
it's like she said in her in a video
she's got a husband that
that looks good
that provides
and she's got to do like of course like
she has to do
like things for him as well to balance
it out i think people when people
well i think today when people think of
a housewife i feel like they think of
the view of they don't do anything
halfway like she said housewife being a
housewife is a job you know
you have to you look after the house you
look after the kids and also
your husband as well
but yeah that's my
so why do you think it was that um
so many women
were upset
alexa go on why'd you think so many
women were upset i think you know what
it is i think it's quite a sensitive
time for women i think in the last year
especially there's been a lot of
talks on women's rights and the topic of
feminism especially when it comes to
you've seen hashtags like not all men
and things like that there's been a lot
of concern around women's safety and
women's independence and whatnot i think
especially in when it comes to social
media you'll see a lot of women who
want to uphold this front that they
should be independent that they should
have it all together and that they
should and
that that is that is a that's a great
thing but i think i think
a lot of people
how do i say this i think a lot of
people
they they are struggling on what they
want their identity to be because
tick tock will show you so many
different sides of how you can be a
woman you will see the side that's okay
independent i make my own money i live
my life i have the time of my life i
yeah my life is great and women see that
we're like yes that's powerful that's
empowering yes i want to live that life
oh she's so motivational she's so
inspiring great lovely i want to
replicate that i want to have my own
money and then
you see the other side of women where
it's like i actually know i want to
submit i want to
i want i want to provide for a man i
just want to live a simple soft life as
they're calling it these days
um
and that works for them and i think
there's just kind of
there's there's just
i think mixed emotions about what people
truly want and i think it also depends
on the state that you're coming to
social media with i think there's been
times when i've come on social media
i've been heartbroken or i've been angry
at man and so if i'm seeing all these
posts i'm talking about independence i'm
thinking
no man bye
i don't want to see you get out of my
business i'm an independent woman by
myself
but then there are times when i come on
social media and i'm just like actually
you know what
that simple life does seem nice it does
seem and so i think there is definitely
that
confusion about a lot of what
what a lot of women want but um i think
rhino is just a sensitive
time for women um
there's just been so much discussion
around feminism and how
um
women treat themselves and how they
should be treated by men and yes you
talk about feminism is you saying
do you think feminism is a good thing
for women
yes
um
i i think it is
um
but my personal belief so there are
different strands of feminism i study
politics so different ways i'm gonna
we're gonna get to the technicalities
yeah they're radical feminists
i'm the radical feminist um saying that
kill all men and all that men should die
like them once that's crazy listen and
it's and it's so hard for someone like
me who i'm a i'm a motivational speaker
i'm a public speaker so i take to my
social media platforms and i like to
advocate for all different types of
issues um but one being women's rights
and
an example i'll give you was last year
and one of my videos went viral i was
talking about the hashtag not all men
and the reason i had an issue with it is
i was talking about it in response to
women's trauma so if a woman is coming
forward to a man like let's say i'm
talking to you actually and i'm sitting
down with you and i'm like okay this has
just happened to me
um
and
without actually taking my story into
consideration your response is yeah but
it's not all men i would find that quite
disrespectful because me telling you my
story is not me attacking you
but there was a lot of people who had a
problem with that and then there were
but then there was also the people in my
comments who were making life much more
difficult for me because they're talking
about yeah but there's women who are
going around saying kill all men
and these type of radical feminist is
like well you're making my job more
difficult because i don't hate men i
want to be able to
support women and talk about women in a
liberating way that doesn't drag any
other but when you say women
yeah
what rights don't women have in this
modern day
you know what i don't think it's the
fact that we lack rights i think is that
our rights aren't necessarily respected
in the same way
um i think
um
what do you mean
that's what i was going to say
i think
i mean there's this definitely the
the gender pay gap but we're not even
going to get into that but that's not
right no we can get into that i don't
want to talk
and i'll tell you why there's a gender
paid up pay gap because a lot of what
women think is a gen gender pay gap
right it it goes off of a few
it's quite late there's a few things
generally women do not take the same
jobs as men
and get paid the same
right so the jobs that pay the most
or the for instance
oil rigging
right if you're out in the middle of the
ocean it pays quite well because you
it's a dangerous job dangerous jobs tend
to pay quite well women do not
uh tend to take dangerous jobs they
leave that to the men right then you
have things like um
maternity leave
women get more leave at work right and
then you get down to what i would call
the crux is the agreeableness and
disagreeableness which means that
women are less likely
to ask for a pay rise
and they're more likely to just accept
their position in their job men are more
likely to ask for a pay rise men are
more likely to say to their boss listen
i can go and do the same job and i can
get i don't know five grand more at this
company if you ain't willing to pay me
i'm out
yeah women generally don't tend to do
that they tend to be like okay fine i'm
at the job because men are more
disagreeable and i think within the um
the corporate structure the reason why
men get paid more is because men are
more disagreeable they're more likely to
go to their boss and say listen i do x y
z and a
right
you need to pay me my worth
otherwise boy like i'll be out women
generally don't tend to do that they
they tend to just accept the job that
they're in and be like you know what
fine i'm here i'm happy i'm good
so the gender pay gap is so
multi-layered is that people tend to
think that because it's actually illegal
if i advertise a job right now
and i say your the the starting salary
is 65 grand
that's to both men and women it's not
like it's 60 grand for a woman and 65
grand for a man
if you apply for the same job as me you
get the same money so there is no
all women are paid less
because they come into the job now
you'll pay the exact same it's that once
you get into the job
how do you work your way up
so i don't i mean this doesn't prove the
point that there's a gender cape pay gap
but it does respond to your point that
you were talking about
men being more vocal and i agree that is
the thing um i was speaking about it and
when i was studying economics but i
think
i think that comes down to socialization
i think from young women are quite
taught to be
quiet we're taught to be okay if
something
like ash's face went sorry
at least
yeah you know how many arguments are
building
with girls in school now
but i don't know about that one i think
so no submissive women in school no
listen back in secondary you see girls
fighting fighting boys like nah man no i
don't know
about that but i think
even that no but i think even then when
you look at add the way adults react to
that
their response to that would be
different if it's
girls getting into fights and boys
getting into fights
i i saw the response to be different
and i think even the way sometimes
parents would treat that like i've seen
cases where i mean i don't have an older
brother but i've seen cases where in
other families where
a sister like a woman has come home to
her family and she's been in a fight or
something's like gone wrong with her and
she's getting all the lectures that
everything's wrong
but then
her her older brother comes home and he
gets into a fight and it's like
okay
yeah okay you shouldn't have done that
but like ah like you're strong in it
like that that's me up there
you know why because men are supposed to
fight
but that's what i'm saying so it comes
down to socialization
so are you are you saying that
see this is a thing though today here's
the like
the kind of double standard women say
they want to be equal to men i didn't i
don't say that generally that's that's
been that's been spoken women we want to
be equal to men we can do the exact same
thing that men can do no you can't
because when it comes to that time you
can't do the same thing that men can do
which is just like
go into your boss's office and say yeah
i need to speak to you
you know what i'm saying like this is
what's going i need more money
you're not ready to do it so
i think um a lot of women are kind of
living a lie
in thinking that
they can do the same things men can do
they don't they can't and go on sorry
question why do you think that is now
today
because women women aren't wired the
same way men are
just like with men um i think our goal
to
to resolve conflict is confrontation
yeah
i think women avoid confrontation
with a man
okay but i have a question i think it's
different
right but right but the thing is when a
man when a woman confronts a man today
when a woman confronts a man today
men confront each other in a certain way
women confront
with
emotion
it's very it's a very emotional
confrontation because like for example
i've seen like situations where
a girl or a woman is not afraid to go up
to a guy like they'll provoke a guy okay
bro
i've seen the situation where so there
was a guy
and there was a girl so she was just
going in the guy's face
like
and you could tell she was trying to
like torn him so he was like for him to
make a move in it
i feel like they know what would have
happened if he made that move he would
have b would have been he would have
been in trouble right
i agree but i feel like they they some
some some girls know they could do that
but the thing is i said so the society's
kind of built in the woman's favor when
it comes to confrontation like that
because a woman knows that she can be in
a guy's face provoke him probably point
up in his face if a guy done that to
another guy as guys we already know how
that's gonna turn out what's going on
yeah we know how that's gonna turn out
do you know what i'm saying so if a
woman does it when she does it
she knows that she's got a whole police
force back in there
the courts back in there
she can she can do that right and still
come off as a victim and that's one of
the things you know when it comes to
this kind of society i think that i've
spoken about and on the show we've
spoken about like men be
women becoming so much more masculine
yeah and men becoming so much more
feminine because a man in general when
he meets confrontation like that he
knows one way to deal with it and that's
with confrontation right but he sees a
woman and he's thinking if i confront
this the same way i normally confront
this
my life's over do you know what i mean
it's actually over and i think a lot of
women understand that power and they
use it to their advantage i agree but i
wanted to i wanted to respond to the
point that you made earlier talking
about um
women
if if they were to go into the same jobs
as men and they wouldn't have
the ability to speak up in the same
sense
um i i think i can agree generally but i
think from my own perspective i'm quite
an outspoken spoken person i've been
like that from young that wasn't me
since they're saying okay i need to be
like a man but i've just genuinely been
quite outspoken if i don't like
something i will gladly tell you i don't
like it if i'm gonna if i'm in at work
or something and something goes wrong
i'll say listen i don't like this this
isn't running for me yeah
and so my question is okay cool
generally speaking we can say that
but
does that mean that there shouldn't be
the opportunity for women to enter those
jobs because there are women who do have
those qualities
opportunity
[Music]
of equality of opportunity and the
quality of outcomes and quality of
outcomes right there's no just because
you have the the the equal opportunity
doesn't mean the outcome is going to be
the same i agree and my my point was
that's that's what i wanted to make sure
that you were getting at i wanted to
make sure that you were
approving of equality of opportunity
because that's what i believe i don't
believe in equality of outcome because i
don't think it's possible for every
single person to be the same i don't and
that's why i don't believe in ultimate
equality between the genders i believe
everyone is different um but i do
believe that there should be equality of
opportunity because if i want to go for
a position and i know i have the ability
to that position i shouldn't be rejected
for that just because it's a
generalization that
women can't speak up so be so so using
that now
to get back to the subject right so if
you're in the corporate or if you're in
that corporate world right right or
you're in the world where you where
you're probably surrounded by a lot of
men
right um
would you say that you've had to become
more masculine
to survive in that environment
[Music]
naturally yes
but to be fair
this is this hmm
you might not like this one but to be
fair
my natural outspoken nature is already
comes across as intimidating to the men
so it it's not the case that they
intimidate me it's the case that i
intimidate them but do you think so do
you think that's masculine though
you can argue whether it is or not
because if if it's intimidating to us
that means it's masculine okay okay but
i think that wasn't as a result of them
because his question was
if you are in an environment surrounded
by men has that programmed you to become
more masculine it wasn't that that
programmed me to become become more
masculine i just had more masculine
features per se
and that it's the opposite way it
intimidates them as opposed to they are
the reason i have those masculine
features does that make sense can i just
say something men are intimidated by
women
generally because there's nothing that
you could actually do to a man that's
going to intimidate him like you're not
stronger than him you know you know what
i mean you're not physical we're not we
don't see him but like oh my god we're
intimidating right here
um
a lot of the time men understand that
one of the reasons why women tend to
think that they're that men are
intimidated is because
when it comes like i said when it comes
to confrontation because if you look at
it like an energy thing right
men know what confrontational energy is
we've known it from the playground we
used to get into fires in the playground
it went on into our teenage years we
know what confrontation is and like i
said when it comes to confrontation if a
woman brings that same masculine energy
to us well i can't do nothing
all right
okay like we don't it's like if i come
back at you with that same masculine
energy we're the bad guy right
i don't think that's what i was
referring to when i was talking about so
what do you think intimidating when i
was talking about intimidation i was i
was referring to
um kind of
i don't want to say my success but kind
of like my portfolio so when i go to
someone and i told them oh
i do this this and this and this and i'm
successful i i'm good at it this is
what's going on in my life it's like
oh and i've been
with people
who
haven't
matched that i don't want to say i don't
they shouldn't they don't need to match
what i'm doing but it's like they
haven't
been on a similar level and i and
there's been
a sense of insecurity
from their standards
no actually wants to jump in
but you're saying that like it mostly
comes from menden because that's like
that seems like a more genuine like a
like general thing like you say that
you're this and that what does it only
meant that that type of way
for me personally is i've only
experienced that from men because men
will come into my life talking about i
need to be the provider i need to be the
success successful one and then they see
me and it's like well as you know
you're the successful one and there's
there's an element of insecurity in that
and from my previous experiences that
has caused the strain because they've
tried to compete with me when it's like
i'm not trying to compete with you i
don't really care about
how much you're doing or how much you're
earning as a company you see you see the
men like that say that
what like what's the general what do
they do like what's the criteria i mean
there's levels to it i think there's
it's interesting i think from my
previous experiences there's just been
it will be the sly comments every time
i'll say okay like for example if i was
to tell you if i was to go to my partner
now i mean i don't have a problem but
like from my previous experiences if i
was to go to my partner now and say okay
i'm going to podcast today oh why are
you doing that oh you talk too much it
would just be like the little comments
that i oh but you're always doing this
or you're always doing that it'll just
be like the little things to try and
like bring me down
and it's like
why why because if you were truly if you
were secure in what you were doing
what i'm doing shouldn't be an issue for
you but understand that intimidation via
success
is not gender specific
but from my experience it has been but
that's that would be subject
i'll i'll say i'll say doesn't that mean
you're picking badly
that yeah that means you're just picking
bad guys maybe you're picking insecure
man i'm picking some dead up man thanks
for that
no no
thank you for that thank you for that
because you're saying you're saying
you've experienced it many times and
that's why you have that that view on
men because
if i like i think i see it as a in a
general way if i say i'm an actor writer
i don't i don't just get it from a type
of whip um only certain people that are
they don't like it i get it from all
types of people men and women in it you
know i mean it's just
fair enough i i don't think like
this is a thing right
so i don't know your life right however
when you're speaking like this and
you're saying okay yeah maybe you've had
to become more masculine right to get in
to get ahead maybe you're masculine
is picking feminine men
whoa
because
masculine and feminine
complement one another
they do they complement one another
maybe you're picking feminine men maybe
you're picking insecure men
she's deep in that love way
you know one thing i've always said and
i actually want to hear your opinion on
this i've always
oh that one hurts that one
[Music]
i always said to myself i said
i have the i recognize that i have these
masculine features um but i've always
wanted someone whose masculinity
overpowers my femininity
no so i think that's where the
submission comes in no no hang on it's
not his masculinity overpowering your
femininity
you want his masculinity to overpower
your masculinity
because men only overpower muslims
that's what i meant i wanted yeah sorry
ma'am that was my favorite that was my
phrasing his masculinity should
overpower my masculinity to bring out my
feminism two masculines can't work right
and so
and so when that's where that's where
the femininity comes in that's what
elsewhere that's the extent to i agree
with which i said in the beginning that
i don't mind submitting to a person in
that aspect because yeah so you
basically saying that's what you're
saying you want so you want someone to
conquer you
what do you mean you're saying you're
saying you want his masculine to battle
your
your your mask i just i don't want to
always feel like i have to do everything
it's like when it comes to a
relationship i think i've because
because i've always been the person
who's like kind of the provider who's
the masculine energy it's like i don't
want to have to go into a relationship
and feel like i have to do it there you
go like what like what um sarah like
what sora said that means you're just
picking bad guys but you're always
putting men you're always putting
yourself in that position but the reason
why you're picking feminine men is
because you're in your masculinity there
you go you're not in your femininity and
so when it comes back to the video that
we're talking about with ali she was
talking about being feminine and being
submissive right and that's the reason
why she got a man and i feel like a lot
of women
out there
today who
are single and wondering why they're
single i'm not saying that's you bums it
excuse me i'm saying a lot of women that
are out there they don't realize because
masculine men
do not want to deal with masculine women
they want feminine women
and so
when
i've heard a lot of women say yeah i'll
be feminine for the right man
femininity
to me is not a switch that you turn on
and off it's just something that you are
just like if you're masculine you're
masculine if a man said to a woman
i'll be masculine for the right woman
don't be like oh
what was this guy talking about like
what you would get yeah like joked on
honestly deep it right think of it like
this if if i as a man come up to you and
say
oh like i'm a feminine guy until i meet
the right woman how are you going to
feel you're not going to feel attracted
to me so therefore it's one of those
things where you have to come
and be
what you would want
your partner to
be in a relationship
so
because me personally i'm not going to
give up my career life that's not going
to happen so my question is okay
how do i still maintain if i want to be
in a relationship
how do i maintain
the career life
and still balance
a feminine energy ah that's a good
question
so what you will find is that most women
who have
husbands and long-term partners
are feminine women
i would say
i'm not even trying to be disrespectful
you're gonna have a hard time
finding a man if you're in your
masculine you're gonna have a hard time
finding a man that's willing to deal
with a masculine woman right i tell you
what men will do and this is going
somewhere and i'm just being realistic
men will have sex with masculine women
they will not take them as a long-term
partner because they know there's going
to be too much conflict in the
relationship
right but that doesn't understand why
are you laughing that's an answer to the
question right he's right but that
doesn't answer the question
so you're saying i can't have a career
no i'm not saying you can't be career
but i'm saying you didn't answer the
question i'm saying you have to become
just like ali said in the video right
because even with our jobs her jobs like
were
assistance to the to the main to the
main guy or so so like i said so to to
become
a lot of the time to become a wife you
have to be more feminine you have to
find your feminine and the thing is
you're cool because you're young
right so you got time i'm just saying
you've got time a lot of women have
spent so many years in their masculine
energy that it just becomes part of
their character
right and then they're in their
mid 20s 30s and they're like oh why
can't i find a manuscript you've been
masculine all your life no man's willing
to deal with that masculine energy so
when it comes to marriage and i think
like a lot of women well not a lot of
them some women talk about marriage and
that's like that they want to be married
they want that long-term partner they
want it they want it they want it right
and i think it's something that both men
and women want they want that secure
partner they want that secure life right
but
understanding the dynamics and the way
it must work is where i think people are
failing okay i have another question
just to follow on from that i'm sorry
i'm sorry you must be asking questions
no sorry this is interesting i think
okay so
we're talking about submission
and we're linking that to femininity is
that the only feminine colon feminine
quality you look for in a woman
no it's one of them um
ash go on you answer that as a man as a
young
man as a young man the thing is with me
yeah like
i just want peace
that's all i want if you could offer me
peace
then then cool because i'm the day
relationships are not oh sweet and
lovey-dovey there's gonna be arguments
on that
the thing is i just want to um if we do
have an argument i want to find the
solution within it if you can come to me
as my girlfriend or my wife and just we
can find a solution together then cool
but um being submissive is in a way
where
because even like i said people see
submissions where oh
uh the men just tells me what to do and
then i'll do it no it's not like that
like it's just
being in your feminine you know what i
mean it's not everyday battling it's not
every day
going on a man's face i'm pointing at
him and showering him nah sometimes sit
down and talk
baby you hungry what's your favorite
dish
yeah for you i agree and yeah like is
that the only quality that a woman's
supposed to have no no but the thing is
femininity is a thing that men are
attracted to just like
masculinity is a thing that women are
attracted to right so
there are masculine things like a man
can
as a woman you know that you can see a
man do certain things he may be a he may
fix something
he may solve a problem you know oh my
god
that was
that turned me on in some way same thing
with men
right men see women do certain things
and they're like oh my god yeah and this
and it's mostly to do with the feminine
not to do with the masculine right and
you know i'm saying just like women are
attracted to that masculine energy men
are attracted to feminine energy and i'm
saying
when it comes to like i say going back
to the video
when ali was saying it and so many women
were talking about oh my god this sounds
like slavery you're talking about
submission all of this kind of stuff is
just like you know what like she maybe
she's figured out maybe she's cracked
the cold
if that's what you want if this is what
women want at the end of the day which
is a marriage right maybe she's cracked
the cold and and i'm and i'm sure you
know i'm i wouldn't bet my house on it
but
the women that were messaging saying oh
my god are probably single women yeah i
agree with that i got a question for you
okay because like he said like you've
had like many situations with men like
saying that they feel threatened or feel
intimidated by your position
so what do you look for in a guy i mean
i look for the masculine features then
why do you get yourself in the positions
i
need to hear that no but like i think
they they present themselves as that i
think i i have my
so you think i have the things that i
look forward to
it's a facade yeah so it's not like it's
not like i see you do nothing just sit
at home all day and think oh yeah you're
attractive no it's not that thing it's
like okay cool i like men who go to the
gym i like men who
work on something i like i like people
who are doing something for themselves
um but it's when
i then get to know them a little more
there's like actually
the work ethic you know i think i
they've been quite good in um
in expelling their masculine energy
meaning being aggressive being like
look look at me don't [ __ ] with me type
energy right
however
in my personal point of view a masculine
man
is logical
he's a leader
he's strategic he's more than just oh
don't don't f with me energy right so a
lot of the guys that are displaying that
you know look at me energy i'm i'm this
alpha type of energy
when you get down to the crux of it they
don't know how to lead they don't know
how to strategize they don't know what
they're doing with their life but they
do know how to expel
their masculine energy like that then
hold then
what what can we do as men to fix that
problem then you can be more you can be
more you can think more because i think
a lot of guys women were watching two
guys fight and get turned on
right
do you know what i'm saying because
they're expelling their masculine energy
do you know what i mean so women you're
laughing because it's true
[Music]
right but
just because two men can fight and expel
their masculine energy
which women are attracted to yeah it
doesn't mean that man's going to be a
strategist doesn't mean that man is
going to be a thinker doesn't mean that
man's going to be logical but the thing
is what you have um mistook for
masculinity is just them ex the
expelling of the masculine energy like
they will watch two guys box they'll
watch mma and they'll be like oh my god
those guys are so sexy when they do that
that man could be a bloody idiot at home
yeah it could be a fool i wanted to
touch a point that you were talking
about peace earlier yeah and i think
a lot of women know that men want women
to be their peace but i think from what
i've seen from some of the women around
me is that they often
that where
the struggle lies is that
sometimes men
not all men but like a lot of men don't
like to show their emotions and that
makes life a lot of a lot difficult for
us because we want to come into your
life be like okay we want to help you
yeah
if there's something going on in your
life like let us in like you can't you
can't wait
hold on no seriously because there's
been so many times where i've been in
situations where it's like okay i want
to be there for you i want to be able to
surprise support you with the love and
care that you need but you're not going
to let me in fact you're not going to
talk to me you cry in front of a woman
what's the next move for them
i can't lie it depends what girl it
depends what girl if i can't like my if
i cry in front of my my girl like my
wife he
she i i hope not even hope she the one
that i pick she will know how to
react to that
but i would prefer not to
if i do
i'll prefer not to
the point is you don't let us in how
could you explain your pieces okay
there's a reason why there's a reason
why okay cool because out of the day
okay highlight if we do cry you're gonna
you just cried the other day she's
already you know what
i'm saying
now you know what it is you know
because if we do you will see us in
you'll see us in a type of way
i think right and that's what happens
like women when they see men they want
men to be right when they see men in
their feminine energy a lot of the time
and i've said i was on the same podcast
and i said something right i said look
women have been asking men to be more in
touch with their feminine side yeah for
three four decades now because
with the feminist movement right the
feminist women said be more in touch
with your feminine side blah
i grew up in a time where i the coin was
turned metrosexual okay i don't know if
you don't remember that that's when men
were coming out of their masculinity and
they were asking men to be more in touch
and the term metrosexual was coined
right and there was men that would
monitor feminist side they would go and
get pedicures they would go and get
manicures they would go and do this and
then what happened was right
when that man turns up
women are not attracted to him it's true
they're not attracted to that feminine
man they're attracted to a masculine man
always have been always will be so
men
need to stop so i'm saying women asked
men to do it because like i said before
men
want the [ __ ]
and they would do anything to get it
generally right so if i've got to
this is what men were thinking if i've
got what i would become a little bit
more feminine and i get the puzzles
all right
and then they've done it
and then we were like uh
i think it comes down to balance when it
when you're in a marriage you're going
to need communication you're going to be
you're going to be able to talk to your
partner like you were saying earlier how
if there's an issue you want to be able
to solve it together how are you going
to do that if you don't if you don't
show your vulnerable attack side at
times i'm not saying okay every single
day you wake up in the morning start
crying in front of me that's not what
i'm saying but i'm saying there should
be there should be a balance like you
should be able to sit down in front of
me and talk to me if there is an issue
and i feel like a lot of men just don't
do that and there's communication
barriers so switching back to the
subject here that was very interesting
switching back to the subject about
marriage because ali in the video was
talking about marriage right and being
married um
is your goal as a man and is your goal
as a woman to get married i want to get
married yes yes
i feel like i think
shark kim samuels but um i think
that actually don't let that about
continue
go and continue i think the meaning of
life is people on it that we come to
just become we were born as one person
and we are able to create create a
community of people from our offspring
in it and i see
i see marriage is more as a duty
people say there's like happiness behind
there that happiness comes with it but
you you're married for a family
to create one that's what i think
is your goal to get married
yes
i would i would once and get married i
want to have a family when i'm older um
yeah let me ask this question then on
leading do you think this generation
that's coming up
are prepared
to be wives and husbands
no
no
you know it is
um shout out shout out to city girl
culture shout out to city boycott you
see what i mean
that's what i mean banda don't want to
marry city girls we don't want that we
want like we want a wife
i don't think a lot of city girls are
our wife
and i don't they don't ask your wife
there's one thing that um
that i know
um
this is this is actually my i don't know
i'm saying this a lot of modern women or
not a lot most
most modern women don't ask to be a wife
you understand
it's like it's like
like it's like going into something
you're not reading the manual i agree i
agree with that but i wanna i think that
comes from
a place of
not being not seeing that as much i
think there's the divorce rate has
increased heavily and so i think there's
now a lot of people coming into broken
families
where marriages are declining divorces
are happening and so
there isn't
a big template
for there isn't like a lot of templates
as to what a good marriage should look
like i think for me i'm quite privileged
because the church that i go to my
pastors are married they've been married
for years and they're currently doing a
series on what a good marriage should
look like in um doing it god's way and
that's really useful because okay cool
the church can see
these are these are two people who are
successful in their marriage okay great
they're talking about their roles as men
and women and what they should be like
in a marriage is great it's lovely
that's a good template that's the manual
as you wish to say it but for people who
don't have that in their lives it's like
well i don't know where i'm supposed to
look because my parents aren't married i
i look i don't see marriage in my family
a lot so it's like where am i supposed
to seek that manual
we're gonna continue that you know we're
gonna read some super chats first but
we're going to continue yeah good point
yeah yeah
um we got a gus
499 superchat says two out of three
universities are dominated by women yet
they still choose lower paying careers
it's not society telling women that they
can't do it
uk economist five pound super chat as a
business owner why wouldn't i just hire
all women to reduce my labor costs
this destroys the myth of the pay gap
sentience 20 super chat my wife will
know
how to react when i cry yes her reaction
will be that her
pee will dry up and she will lose
respect for you because you
because you lack consistency and
destabilizes stability she has come to
rely on from you
right
spoken one five pound super chat you can
be feminine and still succeed in your
career thank you there is strength in
femininity but feminism has told women
it is weak
uk economist five pound super chat
it's simple why would a successful man
want a wife who cannot bring balance
affluent men
need a traditional homemaker
[Music]
mgtow by logic 4.99
ma'am
he's talking to you most men are
straight the ones you want to approach
you
are not gay
they want a woman and not a man and not
a manly woman wake up is what he said c
anthony johnson 10 super chat
men
healthy is wealth find your purpose in
life don't get married or have kids
until 30 understand young men
you can't fight their fight but you can
win the war by winning in life
i like that one
so
thank you for everyone that was uh
donating to the super chat we got we got
one more super chat one more um
sorry yeah one more super chat from
sentient i need to get that up bear with
me
boy
it's crazy yeah um okay while he's
trying to find out um you were saying
when it comes to marriage
marriage is your goal yes
are this generation like i was saying
ready for marriage
you were saying that there's not enough
role models i think yeah there's not
enough templates because you were
talking about manual where do we find
that manual i can't lie do you see all
the celebrities that people glorify like
and who are married just like beyonce
rihanna
like there's
even so
certainties are different because they
live a different life but
they're getting married
they're getting married but then when
people um glorify
other people's relationships yeah that's
what i think is part of the downfall
because every relationship is different
and so what happens is do you guys know
um
uh derrick jackson you see what happened
with the guy derrick jackson terry
jackson jackson oh yeah
he was he was like
right so he was like do you remember the
story like he was like a
a dating coach
and he would tell women how to get their
man and he was married yeah right tell
women how to get their man told them all
of this kind of stuff as a married man
that's what you need to do this guy was
cheating
cheating
right so women would women would
think oh oh my god that's exactly the
relationship that i want to be like
meanwhile this guy is having sex with
whoever he wants to have sex with right
so
when you say there's no template
i always say
your relationship is individual when
people have the hashtag relationship
goals i'm like you do not know what's
going on inside that relationship anyone
can take a picture for instagram
and show what their relationship looks
great
you know what it is
that's what's wrong with our like
generation it's all about image bro
like even with youtube couples they
glorify that youtube couple like
being being a couples this nice thing oh
there's hardship behind that yeah
teamwork
and because that's what like that's what
people see and that's what we're exposed
to that's what we just think that is i
feel like when it comes i feel like
madrid are people in our generation when
it comes to that hardship they don't
have to deal with it that's why you have
these relationships where they break up
for five months you've got a person that
has a that has like
up to like 10 relationships one like
with one guy one girl likes what i'm
saying is they don't know how to do that
it's weak there's no foundation behind
right so then like i said if this
generation isn't
if they don't have something to go by
as young people because i know when i
was growing up yeah i'm a little bit
older than you guys when i was growing
up i had
that model to look to i had
people in my life that were married
in your life as young people do you have
people in your life that around you that
are married um
um
recently yes growing up no
with me
yes i do
but like
i'll say now today
not as much but i feel like i don't need
to rely on them people i don't either
but i think i think my point came from i
think when you're talking when we're
looking at the original video the woman
is talking about how she is succeeding
as a wife and we were talking a lot
about okay
what makes a good wife how what what
should a wife look like and you even
mention the word manual that's what i'm
going by and i'm saying okay cool
where do we find that information of yes
we're talking about femininity but where
do we find that information as to what a
good wife should look like
if we're not seeing those templates okay
cool all right
i don't want to misquote misquote kevin
samuels
from us
from us
but
today now and since like today's
generation you guys like you don't
listening to men is a bad thing you know
what i mean
i would say that the women of this
generation are quite unruly they don't
want to listen to men they don't um a
man speaking
is
now remember
women of this generation talk a lot
about men
a lot of this man that meant this man
yeah a guy puts his hand up like i'm a
man
can i weigh in
no you're just a man yeah
hang on a minute you're talking about my
gender
like can i try and give you some input
no you're not allowed to so what happens
is
women of this generation stay within
their echo chambers and they create all
of these things around what men are and
they've never really asked men exactly
what men want and then when men do tell
you what they want they don't listen
they're misogynistic
you're patriarchal you're this you're
that you want women to be back in the
1920s and you want them to be your
slaves it's like men
have not really changed
what they want from a woman
for like 100 years
thousands of years even they want it
like you said they want a submissive
woman um ali got it right right they
want to they want someone who's feminine
they want someone who's cooperative when
kevin samuel said that the world went
absolutely crazy you know what you know
what
even to the women that do you even pass
on that knowledge on other women do you
know what other women call them pick me
pick me up
i checked ali's profile she had pick me
nation in her um so it's just it's just
it's not even a lose-do situation i'm
the day what's the lady's name again in
the video ali ali ali is getting the
last laugh she's as she said she's
living the life she's
she's getting her back like i said
tonight but because sorry go on there no
no go go because i generally think women
don't listen
i think women have a hard time list they
listen to other women and eat and i tell
you something like you said the reason
why the term pick me came up is because
when they hear something that doesn't
echo the same thing they've been hearing
for amount of time about what men are
like they call them pygmies so
men tend to be more logical it can come
off quite harsh to women i i don't you
know i don't deny that like kevin
samuels kevin samuel says oh he's too
harsh when he says it yeah but
is what he's saying was true that's the
truth that's what people that's what we
talk about as men like behind closed
doors and in barbers that's what we
you want to know what we talk about
that's what we talk about that's what we
want and men would a man would let you
know that you got a bog in your nose yes
you got a bogey there bro
a woman will let you roll with that but
a woman let another woman roll with that
bulgy and be like oh i don't want to oh
oh i don't want to tell her and if she
does tell her oh what's she doing that
for why she doing that yeah they have
this i've and i've said
generally i don't think
women like other women
and when i say that i'll mean this
you wanna you yeah go get it
go get one and the reason why i say i
don't think women like other women is
because as a woman yeah
if you get if we were to bring in
three more women in here right now
instantly the women are going to be
sizing you up
they're gonna be looking at your hair
they're going to be looking at your
shoes they're going to be looking at
what you're wearing they gave me and in
their head they're creating a whole
scenario of
what kind of woman is this
and then when you start speaking they're
going to be like oh what she thinks
she's this yeah
women generally see other women as
competition yeah right and so what
happens is is that
what happens when women don't like other
women
is that because of the competitive
nature yeah
they who were they competing for
they're competing for men wow
the man
so a woman will look at your jacket and
be like oh
it's just that that's not even the right
shade of brown
it's true
i've seen
stay in the it they'll make beef out of
nothing
which is why women change their friends
every day every every three months every
new circle because because women don't
like other women they see other women as
competition the only time men see men as
competition is when it comes to success
yeah yeah they don't see a man i'm not
looking at your hair thinking i'm bored
oh man's got hair
it's just that he's just different from
me you know i mean i just think women
generally do not like other women and i
think that plays into like the dating
market in marriage and i think that's
the reason why ally
got so much hate because
they're not in her position right and
they're hating on that right because
they want to be i agree no i mean but
they ain't going to say that because
they're on social media they're going to
hate
have you found as a woman yourself
that women look at you
and hate yes
yeah and then you go yeah
and why do you think that is that
because of your looks success or both of
the above
both
um yeah both
like men like i said i've said men
in general now become a little bit more
feminine where they start looking at a
man's looks
like oh well he he's looking like this
is that
bro men don't do that
like stop that like i don't care about
what a man looks like if you want to
look at bill gates or you want to look
at steve jobs
they're looking at a man you look at
jay-z but we're looking at his success
we don't care what jay-z looks like we
care that he's got a billion in the bank
that's what we care about we don't care
about the fact that he looks different
so
i think yeah when it comes to
competition men and women have different
competitions and i think
um in the dating market and the marriage
market
personally going back to the video i
think the reason why ally was receiving
so much hate is because women
one probably saw her probably thought
that she was you know attractive and
probably hating on that they won't say
it though they won't say yeah it's true
i saw women in the comment section
saying what can't she get a better dress
what's the point of the does that relate
i was like yo where's the correlation
like not even not even like involving
with the context and i've i've realized
that actually when i talk about some of
the things i talk about on um
my videos there will literally be people
who just start mentioning random things
mainly women i mean sometimes it has
been men sometimes that has been right
okay but it's mainly women yeah they'll
be like oh why should i hello like that
oh why did you do that oh this i'm like
but that's not the point like does it
really matter like if what i'm saying if
it's a 60 second clip of me talking and
all you're focusing on is how i look yes
it's like what because that's women for
you
isn't it it's competitive i've seen that
because
there was a comment on um on ali's video
right and they were saying um oh you
sound like
you can kind of be taken advantage of if
you're a housewife right you could be
taking advantage of and if that man
decides to quote unquote cancel you
yeah from the relationship
what are you going to do
right so i think a lot of women in this
generation have a fear
of marriage
because they feel like if you go into a
relationship with fear
your bounds are familiar you're bound to
vote you know what is i said this i've
been i've been saying this for a long
time life is about risk you know facts
you understand if you
if you go into a relationship hoping
that like
thinking of like oh what if this happens
it's gonna happen you know what i mean
just take that risk because make sure it
don't happen make your partner happy yes
you know i mean oh my god that is such a
good point do you know how many times
i've seen people talk about like when it
comes to commitment oh yeah but this
went wrong that went wrong if you really
want it you will make it work you know
what is you know a lot of people do
people um
go into new relationships with pastor
roma
and
when
when people do that their past trauma
creeps up for them so much
and they don't know that they're
bringing that trauma that is going to
[ __ ] up the new relationship you don't
understand
i feel like people need to
you know what
i've been saying this
therapy
therapy
like even though therapy is like you
have to pay for therapy very that
therapy helps you out a lot man because
it makes you realize
like problems within yourself that you
that you haven't that you don't know on
your surface level of your brain i just
completed six months of therapy just to
put that out there
there you go
would you say yeah
that
women
are happy
in these days and like are women
happy
in relationships generally nowadays in
relationships in relationships are women
happy
not in relationships no
you have to expand on that now yeah
i mean i think
there will be different
reasons um and there's different factors
that will come into play like first one
being because of past trauma okay um
there will still be they might still
have contact to their exes
um
they just their their feelings just
might be all over the place they haven't
healed and that will that will affect
that that's where a lot of the
confrontation will come from there will
there be so much anger and bitterness
that they have gained from their past
traumas that they will just exert onto
their partner they will just take it all
out on them every little thing every
little thing is a trigger for them have
you have you seen that i have seen that
yes um
but and then i think another factor that
comes into play
um wait hold on
if you've seen that you've seen that
from a friend
yes so if you've seen that from a friend
do you do you like i correct them yes do
you correct them yes
male or female like like what do you
what what would be the response from
them like would it be in a negative way
or would it be in a positive way i mean
would they take your take your advice
and learn people don't listen i think
mel in this in this situation when it
comes to relationships not all female
people don't listen
i've seen from my male best friends he's
the number one culprit who just doesn't
listen no matter how many times i tell
him like okay you're not in a position
to be going in the relationship right
now you're not in a position to be
talking to this person right now like
you're not in a good state mentally
you're not fine
he'll go in there anyways or go terrible
come back to me and i'm like well should
i listen to me same thing as a woman
like if i if if i see that
a woman is gonna do something wrong or
if it's irrational i'll call her out on
it um
but then i'm gonna listen how did all
right so how do women react when you
call them out and stuff as a woman
um
my friends
they take it quite well i think but i
think that's because they're used to the
type of person that i am so they know
i'm quite like i'm not gonna take it i
think so if
my my friends just know who i am so if
if
if you're going to do something like
that in front of me
i'm not gonna sit well wouldn't it so do
they
have you got success from that do they
actually listen to your advice
sometimes
but most of the time though okay because
the women sorry the reason why i asked
if women are actually happy right is
because
in the uk
when it comes to divorce
64 of divorces are initiated by women
and in the usa
up to sometimes up to 80
of divorces are initiated by women wow
so
we're talking about marriage or
submission within marriage however it
seems like once women get into the
marriage
right
they are not happy enough to stay within
their marriage because the marriage is
being in the divorce story is being
initiated by women majority of the time
because they're unhappy
and and
the um
and
women start saying oh because menchie
on the top 10 list
of the reasons why women are initiating
divorces
cheating comes in at number nine wow wow
i didn't know that wow i don't know
what's the first so what what's the list
so the third so i'll try and get them
because i haven't got it okay
differences
um someone became the person that they
didn't think they were okay um
family members got too involved in the
relationship yeah um
i can't think of but there are multiple
but when it comes to cheating cheating
is not as high up on the list as you'd
expect as you would expect it to be i
think
women have been sold
a disney version of what a marriage is
yeah they've been sold via the social
medias
via even the films that we watch yeah
the comedies and the rom-coms and all
this kind of stuff and they think a
relationship is supposed to be like this
right when they get into the
relationship is that nothing like that i
think men are more realistic with what a
relationship is which is why are women
actually happy so why are women the ones
initiating the divorces um
i feel you my
i don't know what my answers to it is
because i don't know i
those those some of those things seem
really interesting to me i think
the whole family stuff have you been in
a relationship yes i think so i know
you're young right
so in that relationship that you were in
did you break it off did he break it off
he
you sure yeah you didn't seem too sure
are you sure yeah i'm sure yes okay so
if you have friends right
who are girls and they've been in
relationships
if you were to ask them or because
you've been around your friends right
you know
who's in
nine times out of ten who's gonna break
it up would you say it's more women
breaking up with men than it is men
breaking out women
and my friends no
it's the men breaking up with them
in my fr and like from what i've seen
it's more men
here's the question though was those
girls actually in relationships
and and i think that's a great question
that's great
we're not talking about this
situation
a lot of women
think they are in relationships but
they're not they're not ready for that
conversation and they're not in
relationships right and so i mean just
the other day um i did a review i was i
was talking about lonnie good
right
and lani was on this other show and she
was saying
that she was she used to date
footballers she should date rappers
and then i think mediocre tutorial
reviews was reviewing it and he was like
nah you never used to have sex with him
but you weren't in relationships with
him because
you think that having sex consistently
with a man equals a relationship wow and
so
a man who is going to claim you because
the bottom line is
would that man claim you you're claiming
him but is he claiming you i i've i've
met lonnie and i can't talk about this
one so
okay i'm not
i'm just saying like you know what it is
i think the point is valid though it is
definitely just like
there's there's some girls out here that
they live in our mind where they think
they're in this situation but it's not
really there was one thing that i saw in
tik tok um
yeah some guy was talking about oh men
are happy to waste your time they will
gladly
drag our talking stage for six eight ten
months two years i saw a girl saying
yesterday she ended the two-year talking
stage men will gladly drag it out they
won't put a title on it but what kind of
men though you understand there's men
that don't have no they have to bear
time on our hands and they will do that
but the men
they have time on our hands
we ain't got time for that
we've got money to make we understand so
but the thing is on the flip side women
will happily stay with a man
who they knows wasting their time trying
to change him there you go
go they will happily stay with him
knowing that
no but you know what he can be this and
he can be her potential i can see how
they do
i've seen it i've seen it bro i've seen
i've seen guilt you're putting it to
yourself are you that woman
i've seen girls i've seen girls complain
about certain man i don't want to say no
name but i want to say i've seen girls
that say oh my ex is this my ex is that
red tear
then you're telling me
you've let my man into your yard
man's breakdown you're all there caring
for him same guy
there you go and the same guy that he
was complaining about as whoa
you're all hugging him up comforting him
that's what i'm saying man you need to
know what you want man for real because
there's men out here that we we know we
know ourselves i don't have time for
that man now time to
i don't my time you see with time time
is money time is valuable
i use my time actually you're saying
you've never wasted a woman's time
before me
i don't waste a woman's time
you know what it is listen as a man i
believe we've ordered the day i'm the
day we've all done we've all done that
bro listen like life is life i'm 21
years of age coming now but i'm the day
i'm using my time even though if i'm
even though if i'm wasting time i know
i'm using my time behind that
but i i know my time's valuable
but yeah when uh when a man
[Laughter]
when a man
steps to you as a woman right
and
you know
or you you're attracted to him
within what time frame
do you know or not know you should know
that he's going to be a time waster
i my max is two months max max but
before then i think i normally tell but
if it's if we're still in a talking
stage with two months in you're done
you're done
you're done so so the talking stage can
last two months maximum is that dates
and everything all of that yeah yeah
okay that's the maximum for me
so are you now are you actively looking
to get into a relationship right now no
i'd be open to if it happens are you
actively looking to get into a
relationship right now no but if it
finds me then cool yeah you know and
that's because of what your age because
it's because of
it's not because of my a actually it's
just because
people are not serious
people i agree i don't think people are
serious are you serious am i serious
yeah it sounds like deflecting yeah
i'm just asking bro
accountability is the thing out everyone
is
no it is
i'm serious
when opportunity is presented well you
don't say this earlier a man a man will
be a feminine man will be masculine for
the right ones
right now
my
as a man my main purpose
is my career that's my thing right you
understand
second okay cool if a woman comes on my
life
my wife she's got all she takes all the
boxes then cool but my main purpose is
that
you know what i'm saying if it finds me
it finds people i'm not looking for that
yeah there's people that
i know people that look i know there's
people that look for that
and
because i look at because they're
looking for that so hard it it paths
away from their main purpose in life and
they forget what they want to do yeah
i'm i'm on that i'm sorry but like i
said if it comes to me then cool yeah
all right let's let's get some super
chats yeah guys right some super chats
before we read out the super chats guys
remember to um get on to the calling
show the sos cast it's at 4pm eastern uh
for a call-in show where we will see our
wonderful guest pearl
oh
i'm going to be on that show whoa yeah
oh right okay
i'm
okay guys straight after um check it out
it's at 4pm eastern once again uh the
link is in the description um and yeah
we'll let uh sarah read out the super
chats uh yeah one from jacob mckenzie
five five dollars oh my god pearl what
happened to you did you do something
with your hair you look shorter
yeah i done um
i've done a whole thing with my hair i
cut it off so that's why i look like
this
uh jacob mackenzie um
uh 100
600 says
oh
usd says hundred it's 99 super chat uh
and then we have sentience oh the the
the amazing sentients the amazing
sentients 50 super chat women have no
idea when they ask uh for men to be open
and vulnerable as women
lead they will mold their men into
something they are bore
when you change when you change for her
she will leave you saying that you're
not the man she fell for already oh
zentian speaking facts
big facts sentience you know is that all
the super chats
um
we're gonna we're gonna talk about that
because that was like very interesting
do women change men
into the men they don't want and then
leave them
you have to answer this one first i
haven't seen that to be the k that's an
interesting point i think okay so i mean
i personally haven't seen that to be the
case but that's i think that's an
interesting point
so i'll say this right
in my experience being a little bit
older
a lot of the time women say they want
something but they don't actually want
it right okay so they say they want
something so they say they want a man
who is a leader and he's a boss and he's
a worker and it's hard graft and
that man
is not going to be around a lot
because he's got work to do because he's
trying to
take care of the family the household
etc etc
if as a woman you now complain at the
fact that you don't see your man enough
he's gonna be thinking
hang on a minute this is the man that
you wanted isn't it you wanted a man to
be provider
for the household now you're talking
about time and then
this actually happened to me and then
you say okay cool
i'll work less hours yeah
cool but the two holidays a year that
we'll take in
you ain't gonna be getting that
and you know certain things you're gonna
have to cut back on and then you cut
your hours
and then
it's like uh yeah i want to go on
holiday oh really you want to go on
holiday now when i'm not doing as many
hours as i was doing before
because you wanted me to spend with you
more time and now all of a sudden i'm
spending more time right now you want
the things that
as a man listening to a woman like
zantius was saying sometimes they're
like i heard
and that's what i've said as
misogynistic as it may sound
yeah
men should not listen to women
so they were you think they set you up
for failure i think women will set a man
up for failure and and the reason why i
say that is because women generally tend
to think with their emotions more than
so then logic and emotions can change in
a day to day that's what a balance
becomes it comes back to my original
point i was talking about in the very
beginning where i said i think well a
lot of times
if if
i was talking about social media and how
there was that difference between i want
an independent man versus a um i want to
be an independent woman versus a um
traditional housewife i think that a lot
of women
it would depend on the days like there
were some days there wouldn't be city
girls hot girls just like did they're
cool the other days where i'm like
actually i want to live a soft life this
that i think i agree with you i think a
lot of women just don't know what it is
they want or they think they know what
they want but they don't realize the
consequences that come
what do you think what do you think the
reason is that though do you think it's
like exposure of social media
i think women are emotionally led
i mean they're led by their emotions and
emotions change in the in in in the drop
of a hat yeah i think a woman can be
coming up to her period and think
something on the during that week yeah
and then after the approach is like oh
you know yeah i don't really wanna and
the thing is if is if as a man you say
that you're a misogynist right if you
but the thing is no it's because we
understand logically what is going on
as a man i've been in a relation i was
my past relationship was for 10 years i
was in a 10-year relationship right
and so
i saw being around a woman
for that period of time
i saw her change
on those days
yeah i'm saying like i saw the change
personally and men that have been around
women and not only with that
a little bit of a personal life i grew
up in a household with four women yeah
so seeing them there were times i'll be
like i'm locking myself in my room my
sister's gonna do their thing because i
know because you know when women get in
the same vicinity
they start sinking right their peers
start sinking and i'm like you know what
it's that time and when i see my
sister's doing certain things i'm like
yo i'm gonna i'm gonna hit my room and
i'm not gonna do that so as men when
you're around women on a constant basis
you get to see the changes that happen
within women right and so seeing that
growing up and then getting into a
relationship for so long
i can actually confidently say yeah
when you're at that time you ain't the
same person in fact you're not and the
thing is you might not want to hear that
on this show there was a lady called
eileen that i had a conversation with
right and we were talking about
and she was saying yeah women are
different on their period even pearl was
saying yeah i mean myself was saying
that we are different on our period
right right and
but if as a man you say that
they don't want to hear that they want
to hear that because you're a man in
fact that's why but the thing is the
reason why we're saying that is because
we can see
that you're different around this time
we're not saying it's a good thing or
not saying it's a bad thing we're just
saying you know what
you're acting different right now is it
that time yeah but if you say that it's
trouble i i think i think like like we
were saying earlier it just comes down
to balance i think you should be able to
recognize if you can recognize those
moments you should be able to recognize
when to listen to her or not because i
don't think it's fair to just say don't
listen to women don't um like don't
discard like just disregard her needs
and just
ignore what she has to say because there
may be times when a woman is genuinely
trying to communicate
something that she wants from a person
and that shouldn't be disregarded so i
think there is definitely that balance
that okay yeah if you can see that
sometimes you just
this is you i know i know you and i know
that this isn't what you want as opposed
to actually this is something i
genuinely want now would be a good time
for you to listen to me i don't want to
disregard your point i think it's very
valid in its own right i just going back
to sarah's question
should men take advice from women or if
women oh yeah opinions like my
experience is that women are not
equipped because they don't know the
male experience to give advice to men so
men should necess
really just go to other men
right within their peer group to ask for
advice on how to deal with their
relationship problems and issues that
they have because those men are equipped
and have the experience amongst a group
of them to be able to give the right
solution so i was
i was in a tenure relationship you're
you're basically married yeah right in a
10-year relationship right so within
that time
what i learnt within
because i i'm around men that have been
in like quite long-term relationships um
i know it's you know it's like a myth
nowadays yeah but i was in with men that
are in quite long-term relationships so
one of the things i found
is that when it came to finances
right
women generally tend to spend more than
men right
they generally have impulse buying
right
and if i'm going to
uh
a woman for financial advice
it's a wrong thing to do because most
consumer debt is actually by women women
are the ones that are mostly women know
how to buy women are having amazon prime
deliveries to their house nearly every
week right for something new and a lot
of the time they aren't even wearing
this they're yeah they're returning it i
was sitting in their closet
doing something so i'm saying within a
marriage because um
like i think men when it comes to
marriage need to kind of understand
what it is
to be within a marriage with a woman who
is actually a woman who goes through all
of the cycles that women go through and
that's why i think we lack
we don't know that so i thought i'll be
honest right now a lot of men don't know
that right now do you think you're
marriage material me not right now right
not right now i'm still
20 years i'm 20 i'm 21 years old we're
young
i've got a lot to learn
i want to be i want to be husband
material
but um i know i got a lot to learn
financially mentally and logically where
you're gonna get that where am i gonna
get that i'm gonna get it from my
experiences within um
within
my career and my experience with women
you know i mean
um because like like i think the only
way to learn is just being in it be in
it
i feel like you need to
it's not even is it is it
saying to say you have to kiss a few
frogs to learn
no because experience you're getting
yeah you have to gain experience you
have to gain what you want and what you
actually want as a man or a woman
but um that's what i think i'm going to
gain gain that gain now
do you think you're managing material
not currently no not at all i'd like
like ashley said i think i agree with
this point i would want to be um but i
don't think i fully am right now and i
think i'm still exploring my wants and
needs as well
and that comes through experience um
and yeah what do you think it takes
i'm gonna ask both of you what do you
think it takes for a man
to be a husband
status
i think status status and leadership
i think
because um
how can i say this
and they i think women want they want to
be able to rely on
rely on a man
and
to able to adapt to any situation that
they're given
that's why i think
what do you think it takes for a woman
to be a wife
um
i think
the listening aspect of it is really
important i think i agreed with you
earlier when you're talking about that a
woman who can listen
um
i don't know i need to sit with that
question it's not it's cool because you
know it's everything's a learning
experience yeah definitely um it is so
when it comes to like marriages right
um
there's a lot of
people tend to think that you're not a
prenup is yeah people think that a
prenup is like a bad thing
if you're getting into a marriage would
you as a man sign a prenup i feel like
it's a fail-safe
but
if you do it
is it a set of a failure yeah
earlier is a risk
does that imply marriage is a risk i
think she's like
when i set a prenup that's a question i
don't know
but i feel like if i do
i'm going to i'm going into the marriage
having the idea that this won't work
so if you if you get car insurance does
that mean that you you can you know
you're going to have a crush
that's a really good point
it's just on the days and shorts you
don't know what happens
but like i don't know what happens you
don't have a relationship there you go
yeah but um
so why is it offensive now
to get a prenup and it's not offensive
to get car insurance it's like saying no
but i'm a good driver i'm not going to
have a crash
i'm a fantastic driver you're right
we're actually right on that one
would you sign a prenup next time
um
i don't know there's your answer right
there
the hesitation of the poor said it i
just i don't know like
i don't know
it's cool if you want to say i know i
really don't just say the truth
so you're so you've been with your guy
for for instance you've been with him
for like three years
and he said you know what babe
he gets out on one knee and you know
this is a man that you want to be for
the rest of your life
and he proposes to you and you say yes
and then you guys start you know saving
for the wedding or whatever money and he
says babe do you know what yeah like i
want to get married to you i love you
but i think we need to like think about
a prenup i think that's a sensible
discussion to have
how do you think you'd feel as a woman
if your man came to you
trying to tell you to sign a priest
because he's basically saying this is
what he's basically saying he's been
saying
that some i'm gonna do this but if it
don't work i don't take it as that
though i take it as a level of security
i i'm someone who loves stability and so
if you're coming to me with a kind of
energy that's like
well
actually i care about my finances and i
care about what happens yes i love you
and i don't want things to end between
us but at the same time i still want the
insurance and the stability that
god forbid something goes wrong
i will still be okay i think i would
respect that and the fact that he comes
to me for a conversation before
just saying that we should do it i think
i respect that even more do you know um
the advantages you as a woman have with
a prenup um no i don't okay you said
that sorry do you want it yeah because
you you actually know here we go you
know
should this relationship break down you
know exactly what you're gonna get
you know what you're gonna get i i don't
think she does
that's why that's the point she doesn't
know that so i don't like no because a
prenup is basically a contract mm-hmm
and there's stipulations within the
contract as to what you're going to get
or what you're not going to get right
and so
the thing is is that basically you're
giving away your right to get half of
everything he owns yeah and essentially
there'll be other things within the
contract that will you won't be able to
have by signing that prenup so for a lot
of women it's like well this is my if i
don't sign it then i'm good if
we break up
but yeah meaning
you can take half of a man's wealth
if you don't sign it
but if you do sign it
it may not just it may not be half now
the question now becomes okay i think
for someone i think goes back to one of
my points where i was saying earlier i
want a balance for my personal life that
i still want to have that successful
career side so for me it's not an issue
i don't need your half because i've got
my own i just want to say
shout out to dr dre because he's got
he's in the city he's in that situation
right now where his wife is getting
money
from him did you know that the richest
women in america she is she the richest
no did you know that the richest women
in america yeah are divorcees
do you see that
pre-nup
mad you know you know it's a good way to
get a bag but still so do you think now
marriage is becoming a business then for
women i can't lie
today
no even wouldn't you wouldn't even think
right now that like marriage marriage is
a business move
for marriage is is it is a business move
because former contract's being signed
there's a business deal going down there
you go but
jeff bezos got divorced
uh
um bill gates she got divorced dr dre
got divorced right
tiger woods got divorced
so many successful men
that have put in
work to create their business and yes
their wives were there while they were
putting in the work right and i
personally believe you are
you should get a portion of this because
if i have given you a certain type of
lifestyle right however
you became accustomed to a certain type
of lifestyle because of me yeah you are
no longer with me the entire time so the
lifestyle after me ain't gonna be the
same however a lot of the time women
think you have made me accustomed to
this lifestyle
the operative word being you
have made me accustomed to this
lifestyle so i now want to continue this
lifestyle for the rest of my life i
think that is
is stupid
because i think you just answered the
original question and i think that's why
a lot of women are so angry with ali
because they're saying that they're
saying okay i'm i'm going to be
submissive to these men i'm going to be
the housewife i'm going to do all of
these things he's going to be the
provider living this lifestyle for me if
he now leaves what am i going to do what
do you mean if he now leaves is the
majority of women i'm uh initiating
divorces yeah but i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying
you're taking that point i don't believe
that but i'm saying you're taking that
point that answers
you don't believe that what like
majority of women i don't know i
personally don't like i don't think i
don't have that mindset okay cool
whether you have it or not but that's
the fact it's not no i don't know but
that's not what i said when i said i
didn't believe it
it's not meant to initiate divorces it's
men that are saying let's keep this
thing together regardless of what we're
going through let's keep it together
it's women that are saying no i'm on
i'm unhappy and i'm going to go and see
if the grass screen on the other side
nine times out of ten when women leave a
marriage right they're leaving with
children
they're leaving with the man's home
they're leaving with all of these things
which make them feel happy
but they're going now into a marketplace
to try and get a relationship
right
however generally
men are looking at that woman with their
kids and everything may look good but
he's thinking
that's not my life
that's not my like i've said this before
and it can be a little bit controversial
men over
i have a thing men between the ages of
19 and 29
should not be getting with a woman that
has children okay right because those
are the years like you like you are that
you're trying to build who you are as a
human being right
you're trying to build your foundation
you shouldn't be taken on someone else's
foundation right before your own yeah
after the age of 29
you got to decide as a man if you're
looking for a woman in and around that
age she's probably gonna have a
childhood the question is do you think
men really want that though men
generally do not want to take care of
another man's child generally they don't
i've done it myself like in my 10-year
relationship that i was in the woman
that i was with had a she had a child
from a previous i raised her child
for as mine for 10 years while also
having our own right
so i understand
what men's psychology is from actually
doing it
and then being outside it and looking in
it and be like you know what
nah that's a little bit
it's a little bit weird so i'm saying
when it comes to men getting with women
with children i'd say that the illness
now relies on you after the age of like
30 to say you know what
how often is it i'm gonna find a woman
past the age of 30 that ain't got no
children yeah do you know what i mean
but you don't have to you men can go for
a younger version they can go for a 25
year old you know they can not not a lot
of men can do that
not a lot of men can do they can do what
like go for younger girls for younger
women i think they can because women are
attracted to older men they're men yeah
yeah younger women
100
it's true okay i hear that i hear that
but
how can i say it
how can i say this one
you have to come back to me let me think
about my heart yeah yeah as a young
woman you know you're attracted to older
men right
that's a general rule
so that's why the masculinity you see
more together right a man a man can be
in his 40s and bag a girl that's 28.
okay yeah
like no no no it's not even a problem as
a man there i've been there don't die
no no no no no no no no no no absolutely
you know what you mean because you're
more established yeah i've seen it
you've had more years on yourself
however a 40-year-old woman
if she's bagging a 25 year old man it's
just for sex yeah that's a sugar baby
that's a she just wants she just wants
to have a sugar baby
you know what i'm saying it's not like i
want to have a relationship with this
guy
so like that's why men's they say men's
value increases as they get older
and women's value decreases as they get
older wow
and that's what and i think that's why a
lot that's what kevin samuel that's what
that's what kevin samuels had those
women on there the no danger zone oh
damn thing there he said that but women
didn't like it they didn't like hearing
the truth
and that's like women generally don't
like
they don't like hearing that truth and
the thing is it may sound harsh but it
is what it is once you get past a
certain age you're going to be looking
into men in their 50s 60s you know i
mean if you're in your 30s and you've
got like a couple children etcetera
etcetera
you may want to start looking older
younger so you see that as not not to be
rude because
they see it as baggage in a way
yeah
yeah
so
when it comes to marriage
do you think that men and women
see marriages
differently do you think that the
outcome
in the man's head
is different from the woman
and the outcome in her head it can go
back relating to the whole like
mean of marriage i think it's been so
disney vibe
that
i think majority of girls see marriage
as as like
as a happiness thing
i see well in my opinion i see it as a
duty i think it's supposed to be
something we're supposed to do
if happiness comes over it's a bonus
i want to be married to create a family
to create that stability
did you come did you come from
that house and they that's the thing as
well i didn't come from that i think
that's why i crave i didn't come i
didn't come from that i
i crave it because i
i want to break that side i saw the
damage it was done to my family my
mother i don't want that shout out to my
mom she's a strong mother she's very
strong mom's a single mom
she has um she's mother of like of of um
four right now
but
i see that
and
even though my mom is strong and she's
inspires me she inspires me
but i think it's more
stable to have a two-parent household
you understand
that's why i think
um
i agree with that yeah you agree that
it's more stable to have a two-parent
household
currently
within the
within the black population in america
specifically
72 of children
are born into a single parent family
[Music]
into a single parent family um
when you say
two-parent household do you mean a
married household or just you just yeah
i believe i believe in a married house a
nuclear a nuclear family like structure
that's why i think you believe in
marriage yes so
however
people are getting married less and less
these days um
so how do you think
what do you think the future
for marriage is like i think i'll be
honest with you now for the future of
marriage i think it's
gonna keep the creasing because even
with
like even with a cot like with a topic
that kevin samuels um even spokes about
like the normalization of being a baby
mom and a baby father
that there people even prefer to be a
baby mom than a wife bro like even that
that's
that's a problem itself
like why why why are people
want to be a baby mom than a wife
like
why is it okay to have multiple baby
moms
then actually have one wife that's the
mother of your children
yeah i mean you see when you say
multiple baby moms this is what's
something that i find quite interesting
right so
and then at least half the population of
men in the western world are
childless
they don't have children yeah okay cool
right like half the population don't
have children
sorry the men that do have children
i have them for multiple generally have
them for multiple women
so
why is it now that women are attracted
to men
that have multiple
even even going back you have children
you have to keep it going back i feel
like women don't think logically
they think they think within their
emotions at that moment
let's be honest if you're a guy
and you're sweet talking a girl you're
gonna sway you're gonna sway her mind
you'll look past it you're gonna sway
her mind
but she's not thinking do you think the
majority of men
are able to
talk to a girl sweet
come on if you have game you have game
no the majority of men i'm so drawing no
not the majority not a majority not a
majority but but i hear that because
that's that's i'm that's less like
that's less
but the men that are able to do that
they know the game is so good that they
can put theirself in that position and
that's why they have multiple baby
mothers because i've said that there
there's a there's a section of men
quote unquote average men
that don't have children
that don't have any woman in their life
it's true
their dm's are dry
they don't get any attention just the
job
they just go to work they come home they
don't do nothing it's those top percent
of men maybe even 20 of men that are
able
to sweet talk girls talk to girls do all
this kind of stuff and those in the men
that are breeding which is why when it
comes to baby mothers that's why women
are fighting amongst men because you're
fighting amongst the same men
you're fighting for the same man yeah
you feel like there's no there's not
much twist you know women are missing a
whole section of men
they're not even looking on them because
you know as a woman
you know as a woman
you can walk out your house
in tracksuit bottoms
and a bonnet on your head
and still get attention
you can look you what you think is your
worst the average man
will walk out the house there's nothing
yeah
he will go to his dms
nothing
he'll go to work
nothing that's true
so women have the advantage
it's hard out here i'm telling you it is
for average men it's hard and i think a
lot of the time that's why men
a lot of men are not are not getting
married they're seeing
the major i'll say they're seeing the
minority
of these men
get all the girls like you went to
college or you went to school you know
in school
there was those guys that would always
get the girls
always the majority girl and all the
girls loved him
the same the same stuff
yeah
he could go and pick i want that one
that one because he knew he couldn't
yeah he knew he could yeah yeah but
there was there was the ones where they
didn't get too much attention however
those are the men when it comes back to
marriage those are the men that women
think they can marry
[Music]
they can't
the ones that they can marry and
probably want to marry
are the ones that are missing yeah
yeah
and so
like i said when it comes to like
and and it's my personal opinion that
the majority of women that were telling
ally that she was x and she was y and
she was z
were the jealous baby mothers
wow
it wasn't women who were actually
married yeah
the majority of women who are married
probably understood exactly what she was
saying that yeah yeah
that's what it takes to keep marriage so
i'm saying they want to be in her
situation they want to be married they
want to
have childhood a child within wedlock
but because they're not they have to
hate on that you know what i mean do you
think
women know
because if you look i'm gonna ask you
what you think men know do you think
women know
what it is to keep
a man
right now into this day and age i don't
think they don't i don't think they do i
think
i've i've
had this conversation like on debate
somebody with our social media via
social media i don't think today women
don't understand a man
i don't think they do and i don't
i don't think majority of women are even
trying to understand the man
but i like like like even going like
like we said earlier
women would go they wouldn't go to they
wouldn't gain advice from another man
they would go to another girl
he doesn't know about men and they don't
know about men you understand if you go
to me
which some do but not majority i will
tell you how a guy asks i'll tell you
what we how we think
how our mindset is and it does work but
that's not that's not the majority
because on the day
like like i said if i like like i said
earlier if a woman goes to a woman goes
that guy they're going to say ah you'll
pick me or how you going to a guy
they're going to get they need a clown
for it from that girl isn't it you
understand
but um my my my um
my
advice is if you if you are in that
situation try and get
the guy's um
uh advice and mindset within that
do you think
the same opposite do you think women
know what it is
that
what did i ask it before i asked you do
women know reverse that you reveal yeah
just reverse it so
do men
know what what it is to get to keep a
woman
i think they do
i genuinely think they do i think a lot
of the times they don't want the woman
enough
because i've seen cases where
a man who truly wants a woman
will do anything for her i mean anything
he will find ways
he will find any way
and so
yeah i just think if a man truly wanted
to he would i think like a lot of times
men know what women want or they might
even know a specific woman and they
might know exactly what her wants and
desires are
but they just don't want to say
seriously so they want to do it
interesting what do you think about that
because i don't think men
[Music]
i don't think men most men know how to
keep a woman because what happens is if
they really want a woman they do
everything that she asks she can find
her they can find themselves being you
know feminine and a lot more beta
because they're succumbing to everything
she wants as opposed to being the man
that she they need her to be
which is what one of the super chat said
before i've been i've been well but and
we're going to read the super chats it's
a good segue
a whole story
yeah that's cool we're gonna get to it
um
and then cc five pound superchat says
women will make male allies
campaign with them
campaign with them against patriarchy
okay but then sleep with the patriarchy
listen to what women do
interesting sentience 50 dollar super
chat thank you zentian
if your woman challenges your character
she has someone else in mind she's
comparing you to wow quietly
quietly put the rubbish where it belongs
to the streets and move on a woman will
not challenge the characteristics of a
man she loves and respects wow
we're going to come back to that you
know we have to come back to that
please
caring for a woman's needs and heeding
advice on woman
are separate things
strong men listen and tend to the needs
not the wants
of their woman while discarding women's
critique of their character lead and she
will follow whoa
man like sentience you know
gems he's dropping
guys once again we just want to thank
you for the super chats they're going to
new equipment uh we're trying to upgrade
the podcast we are listening to everyone
that's put in posts in the community so
keep them comments coming um pearl's
really grateful and yeah we're we're
just growing so keep it up you said um
you said you had a story but we're gonna
get well i want to go touchdown but you
said you had a story before go on um
i've even been in a situation where
like my ex has told me what she needs
and i haven't done that
and that's what would lead up to her
breakup because she she basically she
wrote a letter like saying that what she
wants within a relationship
and
i read that as a man and i said i can't
offer that
you know i mean i can't offer that you
know what i mean and
i heard that and she left
and do you think she found a man that
would do it
they she can't end the day no but do you
think she yeah i think she has yeah okay
so it was so it wasn't that
it wasn't outlandish because it wasn't
our lunch because it was thing we're
like
i mean they like we've we've done this
and we've we
we've been to each other like for months
i was like to wear like i don't think i
could do this like i can't adapt to it
but i feel like later
i kind of thought that i can
but this i thought
am i changing myself as a person to
adapt to her
i'm like
i don't know man
to read the super chat yeah again
sentience thank you if your woman
challenges your character
she has someone else in mind she's
comparing you to
yeah
you're saying yeah like it's the truth i
low-key agree it's gonna sound so bad
sorry sorry woman to the woman who i'm
just about to expose you but
realistically if you're if there's
something like
if if you're coming at your man if
you're coming with these little
confrontations even if it's just sly
comments even if it's just little things
it means that
you envision
someone better it might be a physical
person that you already know like it
might be your boy best friend or whoever
else it might be someone you actually
know or it might just be a fantasy of
what you think a man should look like by
the way
if you if
you're constantly trying to change
little things about him it's because
you've seen better or you think you can
do better you envision
him to be someone else
interesting so women play those types of
games
you know you know what i call it
backup boyfriend
you see these guys best friends
you see these guys
i don't think women see guy best friends
to me
i mean men and women i don't have guy
best friends yeah i think i see i see
that as um
next in line
yeah yeah i see that as next in line
yeah i think
i see that i think they got backups
even so because because there's a guy
man come on man
do you want to be in a position as a boy
best friend you understand you you wanna
you know that
you're next in line if this if her
current relationship it messes up i
wanna ask a question is it the title or
is it the friendship because
do you have female friends i don't have
fema i don't i have female friends but i
don't have female best friends okay but
that's what i'm saying is it the title
is it the relationship i don't have any
female friends
no because you're either a potential
something or not
wow
[Music]
like what am i doing with a friend i
don't my friends are men
as a man if i if i'm keeping you around
or even if you're keeping me around i
know it's for a reason
i know it's because you're thinking um
that guy could be a i said i was in a
relationship for a long time
i understood that
me keeping a woman around while i'm in a
relationship would be detriment to my
relationship
like on the flip side if she's keeping a
guy around that could be detrimental to
my relationship so i kind of quickly
learned that as i became single been
single like three years now yeah i
realized hang on a minute
why
do i need this specific woman as my
friend
do i find them attractive
is there something within the chemistry
between us
that could potentially turn into
something most of the time it's yes men
are more honest with that we were like
oh no you know what i tell women i tell
women all the time you don't have a guy
best friend yeah do you know what you do
to check if you've got a guy best friend
tell him to come around your house up
a crazy like crazy time
and get some alcohol in him and then try
and put it on him if he says
what are you doing like crazy then he's
your friend if he says
all right cool i'll go i'll do it yeah
yeah you're afraid yeah he's just
waiting on his time he's waiting for his
time women don't have friends as men i'm
telling you men are
men are hunters
and the thing is men are generally
hunters we know it
and that's why guys hair a girl that's
got a guy best friend he's like no you
ain't got no friend man that uh you
ain't got a friend no no he's not your
friend because guys no guys
that's what i'm saying if the if the
girls that i call quote-unquote friends
called me up or text me at 12 o'clock
and say hey do you want to come around
yeah i'm just gonna i'm just chilling
i'll be like
all right cool
but i know what it's for
you're not going to call me at that time
to come around your house even even so
like why do you need
like two male figures or support figures
in your life
i think you should have
the men and women's lives that they
should be getting like
advice from should probably be older men
who have kind of been through some
things and can give you kind of advice
as to how you know what men do
or your family
this whole friend thing because i always
ask a woman
if you have a guy best friend tell me
how you met him
a lot of times like yeah well you know
what he chirps me but you know we kind
of decided that we're just going to be
friends yeah if he chaps you or you two
were going to do something that means
they're sitting attraction there get out
of here
um would you be okay with it if the if
the male best friend was before you
how would you how would you i would
still ask a question how did you become
friends
because a lot of women say that they've
got friends but something happened
between them at some point and then now
they're just friends yeah if something
happened between you at some point that
means there's an attraction there you go
wow see i've got female friends but like
my kind of rule of thumb is like i'll
only have a friend if i know it's
completely platonic yes
i can never control from your side so i
can never control what they feel but i
would never disresp i'd never leave
sorry ugly no no no
i can't i can i
if your friend put it on you
you'd say no i'm saying no bro i'd say
no on the basis that i respect our
friendship he's a lie yeah
i even support his point i know
if i if if i'm not if i know that i'm
not feeling the girl in in that kind of
way i'm saying
sis
bro like that
you don't see them like that you
understand that you could they could be
attractive but
i don't feel you lacking that vibe yeah
so you could be a lame girl but bro i
don't you're your sister me bro okay
fair enough if the female adds value to
your life
like in certain ways shape or form i
don't know like if it's a situation
where it's like the advice that they've
given or like the business ideas
visions um and certain things like that
like i don't see why
it's you can't value that friendship in
fact over the your
sexual urges yeah i'm not saying that
you're going to go there yeah i'm saying
because if you see her like that it's
not like you're actively trying to go
there yeah i get it okay what i'm saying
in a certain setting
and she put on her feminine charms
you're going to be like
get off me you're crazy yeah men can do
something some some man can do that i'm
not saying they can't because i've done
it okay i'm not saying they can't but
i'm just saying in general
men
will take the opportunity hundred
percent india you're not wrong about
that they'll take the opportunity
majority of men were like oh free free
pom-pom yeah you're not wrong about that
yeah facts and think about it afterwards
oh we shouldn't have done that but those
are those are the people that can't
that's not
like it's not normal yeah that you know
i mean they'll take the opportunity so
you actually believe men and women can
be friends yeah they they can they can i
think just because you're attractive
doesn't mean i'm attracted to you i
think
yeah i think if i know i don't want to
do anything i don't want anything with
you like that you are genuinely just my
friend i'm keeping that because i
disagree eventually the friendship will
end i it's not something i'm going to
keep around but i know from my side
i don't want this to go anywhere else
and that's it
and if it
if you try for it to go somewhere else i
will end the friendship i think women
know when a guy actually likes them oh
yeah
and they kind of keep him around they do
knowing that they can just keep them
when they're down
yeah give him a call when they're down
and be like oh you know
yeah you know what you know what you
should do you know
i can confirm that that's true
it's true guys get out of the friend
zone man
seriously get the hell out of the friend
zone be and pick up your balls and get
out of there all right the only time you
should be in the friend zone is when you
decide
if you want to be in there
i think because there's there's choice
i think of me
i feel like majority of the like
the friendships i have with women i've
decided to make that as a friendzone
thing
you decided yeah i feel like i decided
yeah i've decided because i'm the day
i can see you as a friend but there's
some qualities i don't like that i can't
i don't think
works in a relationship term of things
you know i mean you need that ick yeah
to put you off
this ick
this is real
she's not even wrong about it it's so
real so it's a psychological thing once
i realized that you have something i
like
i really value
even even if i s even if i tell myself
no i'm spying i can look past it i could
i can't i just can't what bug means what
brings on the ick it's actually it's a
natural thing it's small things though
it's once i just what do you my question
is what do you see in a woman that makes
you feel like oh
there's something there's definitely
something hold up
girls i understand the ick because girls
look to disqualify men but men usually
look to qualify
yes like so the guys who don't have an
itch we don't have an ick we might have
a reason now guys will have sex with a
hole in the wall
okay cool
i'll still see what's good like what's
going on by that
but then again this isn't the same as a
relationship oh so
yeah but when but the thing is
relationship so i guess he's talking
about from a relationship from a
relationship standpoint yeah like he's
like oh there's things that put me off
you that i just physically wouldn't yeah
if you're looking for her as a
relationship type person like yeah yeah
yeah i get it but like i said a lot of
guys ain't even looking that far ahead
it's fair enough yeah they just want to
you know they don't want to smash they
want to do the thing
um
listen
guys it's like midnight right seriously
yeah it's like midnight um we're gonna
kind of wrap up now but um
thank you both for coming yeah thank you
um thank you all before we get going
though we've got some super chats to
read i believe cool uh we got some
stupid super chats to read
we could do sentients man like
zentangles
from the last time oh that was from the
last time
one more yeah
okay cool let's read the last super chat
um it is from
sentience again no no no no no no it's
not exciting
hang on is it from
infovator
all right informator uh 10 super chat a
big problem is people conflate the
difference of ideological feelings
and real world behaviors
simple undeniable example is nice guys
finish last
that one let's do that before we go nice
guys finish last
um
you you have this is all you
need do you guys know these emails i
know it's easy okay so i was oh yeah
i've done a z mills interview i would
i've done a conversation with these
emails right
yeah and she said specifically
yeah
that women
look for guys
who have a quote-unquote edge
that's what she said an edge whatever
that edge is
right so she was saying when it comes to
nice guys nice guys don't have that
quote-unquote
edge
right which is why they finished last
because women generally want a man
with an edge because it's new is it
because it's new i think whatever that
edge is
it could be someone who that's why a lot
of the quote-unquote pookies and
ray-rays and road guys get a lot of
girls because they got a quote-unquote
edge
right the other guys don't so is that
true do women look for a man with an
edge i think for me personally i look
for someone with confidence if you have
a con confident aura like an assertive
or it doesn't it doesn't always have to
be like okay you tell me what to do or
you put me in my place no it's like but
you did say that before though because
you said you wanted a man that can
overpower your masculinity yeah through
his assertiveness or confidence i'm
saying i'm saying it doesn't always have
to be that it's an energy that i can
feel if you come to me and it's like
okay cool
i can i can feel the confidence i can i
don't mind you being nice but a lot of
the times the nice guys
don't always have that full confidence
or they all don't always have that
assertiveness where you can
yeah so you're saying that men need to
be like
edgy just to get away with that but
would that wouldn't that be your edge
then i guess yeah i'll say i'm saying
from absolutely yeah what has been your
experience do you think that the men
with quote unquote edge get the girls
it's true they do because they
they like the way they handle the i call
it sauce in it the way they handle the
sauce is different if you're just a
typical guy
like average joe then you're not going
to get that kind of exposure to women in
it if you're different with it
then you will
you know i mean that's what girls like
so imagine the majority of women now
let's say 80 percent
are looking for the guy with the quantum
core edge
right
the guy with a quote-unquote edge
probably could be like fake centerman
so 30 of men
are now getting 80 of
women and there's a whole seventy
percent of men like
what about me
do you get what i'm saying and that's
why that's why they do to get them
courses from andrew tate
and all them things there because they
wanna
because they they're trying to get that
son like pick me men there you go is
that what it is pick me men it's picking
me men yeah but like the other thing
you've got to take into account oh john
i forgot but i'll come back okay no so
yeah like the majority of women
are looking for the minority of men
they want the special type so if the
majority of women are looking for the
minority of men
those minority of men no they got the
majority of women to pick from
which is why the minority of women are
fighting over so the majority of women
are fighting over the minority men yeah
and that's why women think men are trash
that's right because you're looking at
the trash man that have multiple options
which is why when men tend to breed they
tend to breed with multiple women
because they can because those are the
women looking for them
yeah the other thing you take into
account is nice guys will tend to
exhibit traits that they're not able to
be aggressive because they're trying to
show a nice side of them and
aggression in itself uh is a
characteristic that women find
attractive that's right like i said they
want to watch a man fight so they'll
look a woman will look at a nice guy and
go um he couldn't protect me he couldn't
protect me if needed to he couldn't turn
off the jets if needed to so therefore
the attraction for that nice guy isn't
there
and then you find those women who
tend to try and turn up the jets on the
man to see if he can
and men get thinking oh my god i need to
be more manly and get themselves into
some
dumbass trouble yeah how many men are
sitting down in prison because they
wanted to impress a woman because they
want to turn on the jets
right
are now dead because of women because
you want to turn on the jets in front of
because they wouldn't be impressed i'm
telling men
stop that [ __ ]
okay stop it start being yourself and
stop getting yourself into trouble okay
because of women okay
hang on a lot of the time
women will lead you down a path because
when you're in prison
they're outside having sex with your
best friend they're not waiting on you
bro why they're not waiting on you okay
stop it they're calling you on the phone
thinking that you're the one no that's
what we call i say that's dying for
nyash
no it's not worth it they said it best
there you go
they said it was santander shout out to
him you were gonna say something though
i was gonna say so okay so for the men
who are watching this and who are who
feel like they are in that category how
do you recommend they approach women um
oh we had that conversation last time oh
okay we were saying um no no it's fine
we were saying um women were saying
there's a time to approach women
and it's not at two o'clock at night oh
i agree right i agree however if you're
the right man there's no wrong time to
approach a woman there you go
right you're saying the right time a lot
of men don't know how to approach women
which is why a lot of men when they do
approach women come off as a little bit
creepy
right because they probably geared
themselves up
in their head thinking oh my god i've
been looking at someone for so long
they don't know how to do it so when
they when it happens we were like
okay what's this guy doing right
how to approach a woman
how i approach her i can only look at me
like me
um i look at her
and i find something on her as a woman
that i know she'll be appreciative of so
if for instance if i'm going to approach
somebody like you know what your nails
are really getting your nose done
[Laughter]
that's what i'm saying guys
find what a woman you know a woman likes
yeah and compliment on her or compliment
her on it or even ask a question about
it it's a shoe in the door
it's a study you have to learn you have
to learn these things okay quick little
question i don't know if it will be
quick but um
okay so we're talking about masculine
and feminine energies what do you guys
think about women shooting the shot
go on go on mates you're going to school
i can't lie
as me i don't mind that i think
it sure it attracts me because it shows
me what you want in that moment of time
even so even so it takes away
my masculinity
i
i will do i do my best to insert my
masculinity when you have shot your
moment
do you know what i find with women that
shoot their shot with me i'm gone um
they're not forthright
they start saying certain things hmm oh
do you know what
yeah i watched one of your videos it was
really good actually you know
let me tell you something i'm smart
enough to know that if you're saying
that to me and you're in my dms that's
that's you trying to that's what we call
peacocking right okay you're trying to
you're trying to
fan out you're trying to show me how
great you are
without saying
what you want to actually say so you
want me
to now
come to you after you've made the move
but the move you're making is very
subtle and i feel like when women shoot
their shot it's very subtle
generally still waiting for you they're
still waiting for you to shoot the shot
after they just kind of just through the
ball there you go take the ball like
just shoot the shot you know what i mean
i feel like women in general don't want
to shoot their shot properly because
they're scared of rejection
when a woman decides that this is the
man that they want
they have
if a what if because men are used to
rejection
men get rejected all the time because
i've been in a position where where
girls shoot their shot but i guess my
question is properly shoot their shot
like like oh my god you're so nice
what's your name yes yeah i've been in
that position really i know
i will i'll show them the same energy
from that but my question is would you
actually take that person seriously
because we're here talking about
masculine energy is how you want to
approach that is that a little bit too
masculine do you see that woman as
somebody yeah i don't see it as
masculine i see it as going yeah so i
was literally about to answer this so i
was speaking to my uh
cousins and brothers about this and i
was saying that as a man uh you have the
mindset of a hunter and essentially if
your prey came up to you
asking
yeah come and eat me it'd be it's kind
of repulsive and it's like put barbecue
sauce on himself and we're like look i'm
tasty what then happens is when you have
girls approaching you moving to you
right
yeah you might smash on everything but
you're not going to take them seriously
as candidates because you didn't pick
them
you didn't select them you weren't the
person that said this is mine i want
this that was the question i was going
to ask you exactly
so
what if you're used to that
if you're used to that it's fine like
you you're going to get that attention
yeah that's what it is as a man if
you're used to that women shooting a
shot yeah
it's probably because you're in your
feminine
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm just
the reason why i'm saying that
is because oh because generally when a
man is in his quote-unquote masculine
women see it and they admire it but i
genuinely because they're a little bit
it's a little bit like oh should i talk
to him oh my god should i speak to that
guy what i should do is just let him
know i'm in the vicinity
i'll let him know that i'm in the
vicinity right so i'll just make little
i don't know little i don't know
moves or
gestures to make him know i'm there but
i'm definitely not going to shoot my
shot at him
ladies don't shoot your shot i've been
saying this thank you i'm not trying to
disrespect you bro no no no i i get it
i'm not trying to disrespect you i'm
really not bro i'm not i'm not i'm just
saying like
women that are in there feminine
generally
don't really shoot their shot
but but the thing is like i said before
i feel like men have become more and
it's not a disrespect a lot of men have
become a little bit more feminine and
women have become a little bit more
masculine
and so
that whole city girls
cardi b generation yeah always talking
about
their whap yeah
do you know what i'm saying like that
kind of generation is like look at my
team look at this
it's that's now the that's now how women
kind of shoot their shot because once
you show people what you got
men are going to be like oh oh damn
that's what you got
i shoot my shot as a guy but it does
happen sometimes like
it will happen that someone will take
the initiative to come it's happened to
me yeah it's it's actually happened to
me as a man like and i've been like do
you know what like i said before
masculine women men will definitely have
sex with them yeah listen because a
masculine woman can be dressed in her
most feminine
do you know what i'm saying she could be
dressed like oh my god she looks amazing
but her energy is masculine wow right
and a man will definitely have sex with
her but what is he going to go
to go to the next level that's going to
be a problem yeah
that's going to be
it's gonna be a problem
but yeah
ash
yo before we go we got one more we got
one more super chat big boy super chat
oh he's a big boy
okay oh check this one out oh wow hang
on let me let me have a look at this
super chat you say big boy super chat
yes yes let's hear it let me see this
girly
michael fedele 99.99
i disagree when a man has many many
quality selective sexual options he can
have females as friends without any
interests in those women
big fats okay that's the anomaly but
that's a big factor okay
that's fair enough that's foreign um
listen
i've enjoyed it yeah man it's been good
i've enjoyed it and before we get going
um can you just tell people where they
can find you
with your socials cetera my name is
ashley duran you can find me from ad
official
this is zero the o
i'm on instagram tick tock snapchat you
can find me all there i'm an actor i've
been acting for three and a half years
and then yeah so can we find you let's
go my name's alexa asme that is spelt
a-l-e-k-s-a-a-s-m-e
you can find me pretty much anywhere
instagram
youtube tiktok
anywhere i'll be there you can also find
me at performances i'm at a lot of open
mic events because i do poetry and there
you go so yeah
you can find me links in the description
for everyone's
links in the description you can find me
as sarah garvey if you haven't already
subscribed to my youtube channel you
better go do it if you haven't um gone
on my instagram it's the black opinion
and if you haven't gone on my twitter
it's sara garvey i'm s a r a
g a r g-a-r-v-e-y
everywhere um thank you all for tuning
in thank you both for coming thank you
thank you so much we out of here
peace bye-bye
and that's a wrap that was a good one
wow my gosh